[Music]
it's totally a blessing it's just really
real
yep in December Khloe Kardashian
announced she's expecting her first
child with her beau Tristan Thompson
during night two of the Keeping Up with
the Kardashians midseason premiere we
got to see their big reveal I think it's
perfect timing that my family's here and
all your family's here to unite as one
and yes announce me we're having a baby
mama Kris Jenner and sisters Kourtney
and Kim were all at the family barbecue
to celebrate the good news but Kendall
and Kylie couldn't make it so they found
out via FaceTime I am pregnant
[Applause]
fans wondered would the episode also
address Kylie's pregnancy but
unfortunately the 20 year old was
noticeably absent from the show in
September et learned Kylie is pregnant
with her first child with boyfriend
rapper Travis Scott she has yet to
confirm the news and has remained
largely reclusive ever since Khloe on
the other hand was thrilled to discuss
her pregnancy when et spoke with her
earlier this month I feel great and I
feel so lucky to feel so great you are
tired but it's such a beautiful thing
[Music]